Déborah tu auras envie de faire quelque
chose déjà la poitrine parce que j'ai
des petits raisins secs
c'est pas un petit peu le nez qui a un
peu trop mais bon
Laurent faire quoi toi
ça me ferait du bien mais
Sophie tu refais quoi ce que je devais
faire déjà donc tout va bien
esthétique
mais alors là il est c'est la colère
donc voilà j'ai fait ça j'ai fait un
petit peu plus de volume dans la bouche
oui bah oui quand même
ça va c'est pas trop tu es magnifique
Rachel tu as envie de faire quelque
chose toi moi j'aurais bien aimé mais
naturellement avoir quelques centimètres
en plus mais comme je suis hyper
trouillard de faire des allergies et
tout je vais faire même si je sais que
je devrais parce que le temps
aux yeux bleus c'est raté oui ben oui
oui tu peux mettre des lentilles mais je
supporte pas non moi j'ai peur j'ai peur
je peux rien refaire et j'ai fait une
fois du Botox pendant 6 mois j'étais
énervé les gens me disaient ça
je suis pas du tout énervé ça va très
bien je suis comme ça
donc les pauvres les gens ils savaient
pas Philippe qu'est-ce que tu refais toi
si moi j'ai toujours dit que j'avais le
cul plat donc je me ferais bien bomber
le cul avec tout c'est important le cul
avec
ce que tu fais tu n'as pas non non
justement je suis un des seuls traiteur
après avoir le cul bombé je sais pas si
c'est pour plus pour ma femme quand elle
attrape derrière
laisse tomber est fini pour plus
rien ça avec ton épouse que nous saluons
toi derrière
il est plein
il est dur
j'étais sûr qu'elle allait le faire oui
non mais tu as raison ma fille on vit
qu'une fois vas-y
[Rires]
promis qu'il fallait commencer jeune
donc je considère que c'est trop tard
donc je reste avec ce que j'ai mais
comme je suis très endurant de toujours
ça va vous aurez toute sa l'usure
[Applaudissements]
moi j'en ferai Isabelle s'il y avait
beaucoup d'argent j'en ferai Isabelle